seth's book is called yearbook and um
really it's great
i'll tell you this for those of you who
love lists seth
has a list of his favorite fast food
restaurants
because uh you got burned by an angry
whopper one time
yeah you went to burger king i'll set it
up for you you went to burger king you
ate a whopper and then you ended up on a
plane
right before you were taking a flight
and you had a strange reaction to the
whopper well i
also was very hungover and had eaten a
really powerful wheat brownie so i there
was two other things at play
and it was very early in the morning and
i uh i went to a burger king
which i would rank as the worst fast
food wrestler
i noticed a product called the angry
whopper which was a whopper with like
chipotle
and jalapeno peppers and it was like a
nuclear
uh spicy whopper and i guess part of my
brain was like
i think it was like electro shock
therapy i was like maybe this will just
like shock my system back into place
like maybe this will be like just a
powerful
weird thing to introduce into my body
that it kind of just like
realigns everything so i ate the angry
whopper
very fast i downed it incredibly fast
and it actually
made me feel a little better for a bit
so i get on the plane and i fall asleep
right away um but the angry whopper i
think because of all the jalapeno and
the chipotle and all this stuff i start
and i'm hungover and i'm really high
from this wheat brownie i'm sweating
like like a like a crazy amount like
truly like i am i am drenched in sweat
and i fall asleep on the plane and am
woken
uh by a a stewardess shaking me awake
um her hands clutching my very sweaty
arms
and she's screaming you've had a seizure
you've had a seizure which was a very
startling thing to be awoken to
also because i didn't i felt i felt fine
and i didn't i felt good honestly
and i didn't feel like i had a seizure
and but the woman was convinced i had
had a seizure
and she yells is there a doctor on the
plane and at which i was like
whoa whoa whoa and then a an arm shot up
and was like yes
i am a doctor and a doctor came over
starts checking on me
starts doing the flashlight eye thing
and i'm like i i don't know honestly and
the truth is like i don't [ __ ] know
like
i'm high still i have this angry whopper
i don't know what's going on i'm just
confused and disoriented
i'm hoping i don't think i had a c i've
never had a seizure so in my head i'm
like i don't think i had a seizure but
whatever i'm gonna let them check me out
so they check me out
i feel okay they're like just sit here i
turn to the woman beside me after the
doctor leaves and i'm like
did i have a seizure and she's like i
don't think you had a seizure
i think you just she's like you just
look she's like you're just sweaty
you're just gross
i don't see a guy who who had a seizure
and so it kept so in my head i'm like
fine thank god but then when the plane
laughs they come to me and they're like
just so you know
an ambulance is waiting for you um
because of the seizure and that's when i
was like i can't
i can't do this anymore i had to like
and i got off that there was a
wheelchair waiting for me a stretcher
all this [ __ ]
and i like i was like i i was like look
i had a weed brownie and an angry
whopper i think that was wrong with me
if i'm being totally honest